oh
[Musique]
hamad
bonjour neo 4 degrés sud tous degrés est
alors à votre avis
vous avez raison je suis venu explorer
l'habitat indonésien
prêcher boogie la voie lactée au coeur
de sulawesi
je viens voir ici comment construit les
maisons dans cet archipel qui s'étend
sur près de 6000 km entre l'océan indien
et l'océan pacifique
quel genre de maison on habitait sur ces
îles il y en a plus de 17000 ici où la
terre tremble souvent il faut savoir se
protéger des pluies tropicales très
forte mais aussi des tristement célèbres
tunnel ce qui habite au bord de la mer
c'est la malle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
un
poste
il m'a caché d'avoir failli à va
première escale chez les boogie
étonnant je pensais que leur maison
était sur pilotis en fait elles sont
flottantes
quand il ya du vent c'est pas trop dur
de vivre ici quand il fait est mauvais
oui ça dure quand il ya du vent et aussi
pendant la mousson
autrefois on a été inondée complètement
c'était le 2 mai je crois
c'est quoi la profondeur ici très
profond un mètre cinquante
et pendant la saison sèche vous faites
comment alors
ça arrive parfois qu'il y ait plus de
détails
je n'en reviens pas de ces maisons
flottantes
lébougui sont les rois de la pêche
dans la cuisine de fortune on me prépare
un délicieux mélange du poisson mariné
dans du citron vert et de la noix de
coco râpée et grillé
alors c'est bon
mais quand il n'y a plus d'eau alors
vous ne faites commun
j'emporte ma maison au milieu du lac
on peut dire que ma maison suit le cours
en quelque sorte
incroyable lébougui déplacent leur
maison en fonction du niveau des eaux du
lac
[Musique]
c'est le début du voyage et ce n'est que
le début de mes surprises
[Musique]
j'ai pris la route en direction du pays
mamassa au coeur de l'archipel de
sulawesi
l'indonésie 250 millions d'habitants ce
qui saute aux yeux et aux oreilles c'est
un mélange unique de religion empilées
par l'histoire un millefeuille étonnant
de croyance encore vivante
alors partout dans l'archipel les
esprits divinité ou démons sont dans les
maisons ou jamais bien loin
plus vite plus vite il faut qu'il aille
plus vite l'yonne est mon ami indonésien
avec qui je fais le voyage
[Musique]
voilà en fait on est on est un peu loin
mais au coeur de sulawesi
non voilà le lycée et skoda c'est une
bonne piste
mais c'est pas la voiture qu'il faut
cette attente
ses seules ces lafitte c'est toute la
série quand même
je vais avoir des maisons qui sont
vraiment exceptionnelles ne serait ce
que par la forme de leur toit déjà
[Musique]
16 heures de piste mais ça valait le
coup
ah ouais
c'est là elles sont vieilles une rangée
de maisons au milieu des bosquets de
bambous qui sont penchés un petit peu
lassé elles sont dans leur jeu s'est
passé par construire un on va jeter un
oeil tout de suite là la légende raconte
que les mammas assouad est venu de la
mer fuyant l'islam pour se protéger dans
les montagnes
c'est pour ça que les toits en la forme
d'une coque de bateau renversée
la plupart des toits c'est des feuilles
de palmier plein plein de feuilles de
palmier assemblée comme ça c'est une
soit sûrs semi-perméable
ya une procédure à une fois il faut
aller doucement et
[Musique]
ils sont accueillants mais il voit très
peu d'étrangers
[Musique]
on a invité dans cette maison par le
chef du village on va suivre
salama
salamat baggy
[Musique]
la terrasse c'est la partie semi privées
publiques et là on est vraiment dans la
cuisine en fête à l'arrière de la maison
salama tiens
c'est incroyable à ces aléas les routes
cette cuisine a
[Musique]
classé la cuisson à l'ancienne où l on
parle de toi là c'est la cuisson à
l'ancienne avec le feu comme ça et la
fumée évidemment passe à travers le
stock de bois ici et ensuite ça ça monte
dans la toiture et du coup sa dépose une
couche de qui protège l'herbe parce que
c'est de l'air de la toiture
il est bien leur truc l'asie c'est ce
bon goût et
ça ça me plaît
pourquoi que ça met le feu à la
structure c'est un un socle en bois très
dur imputrescible et par trimestre de la
terre et sur la terre ils font le feu la
terre et philippaerts cuir ça fait une
sorte d'argile et du coup ce le feu peut
pas se transmettre à la structure de la
maison
bon on va visiter les champs
c'est petit c'est la bri quoi
ça c'est bien
ça c'est tous des assemblages simple
mais mais costaud car il ya une grande
tu nous faut être souple je suis mal
pris là je me suis mal pris en feu et
voilà je suis dans la chambre trois
petites pièces sans meuble juste
quelques dates qu'on déroule pour dormir
bah la paix ou est à 1600 mètres
d'altitude
les maisons sur pilotis profite du
moindre souffle d'air
à ces systèmes de distribution d'eau aux
maisons avec bambou et petits tuyaux
et là c'est le village on voit bien
l'alignement avec toutes les maisons
orienté est
et en face les greniers à riz grenier à
céréales principalement durée ici chez
les mammas à une des pièces maîtresses
des maisons c'est le pilier qui supporte
le toit symbole de puissance il est
décoré de cornes de buffle la maison et
vieri ce qu'il ya des générations et des
générations de gens qui sont qui sont
nés là dedans et qui sont morts dans
cette maison
c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
un bon bah centrale scénarii soit alain
monsieur des mis à nu ce chef du village
de bala paix ou mans mène vers une
maison particulièrement décoré et qui
semblent peintes en noir
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce symbole là bas
c'est le symbole de la mort regardez le
centre représente l'image de lens est
c'est une décoration
oui si le motif torregiani
mais
[Musique]
selon notre coutume
la maison doit être orientée à l'est pas
à l'ouest
l'ouest c'est le signe des cimetières
alors vous voyez
on construit toujours les maisons face à
l'est là où le soleil se lève
pour
explorer les maisons en indonésie c'est
se frotter aux dieux aux démons et
autres animaux extraordinaires
mais partout dans ce pays les forces
obscures viennent d'abord du sous-sol
des volcans direction java une des îles
les plus actives de la ceinture de feu
du pacifique
puis c'est le volcan merapi
régulièrement ils crachent le feu et
donc salle avons taillé les bouddhas qui
décor temple les maisons
plus que partout ailleurs dans le monde
ici les religions sont vivantes et
surtout elles coexistent
au pied du volcan merapi la ville de
yoga carte à un million et demi
d'habitants régulièrement menacés par
les tremblements de terre
[Musique]
le mélange religieux de java puise ses
sources dans le bouddhisme l'hindouisme
l'islam et le christianisme
le tout sur une base d'animisme qui a su
tenir le coup il faut le voir pour y
croire
g
[Musique]
au milieu de la ville de yoga carthage
appeal au cra tonnes le palais du sultan
restaurer au début du 20e siècle
[Musique]
le crac honnête une série de cours
carrées aux papillons en teck massif un
mélange de styles javanais avec des
influences coloniale hollandaise
le palais c'est le centre de la ville et
aussi le coeur de l'univers selon les
croyances de java
c'est cox a créé ça non
d'avoir un nom cela mon avis on ne mange
pas
jeudi il faudra un coq comme ça à
l'elysée long
je sais la matte
les
français
mouzon 75 ans et guide au palais elle a
appris le français au lycée parce que
son prof était séduisant un français
plus qu'approximatif
moi j'avais rendez vous éco tout le
temps mais l' idéal il est en commission
d'enquêté fait peut-être pour 800 points
de cette semaine et donc on va aller
comme ça et saint-palais vivent les gens
me parlent français lui aussi
on va aller voir le spectacle de
marionnettes après 16 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
au palais on utilisait sa pour la larme
en cas d'incendié oui
mais chez vous en plus petit c'est un
rouleau à pâtisserie
[Rires]
[Musique]
il faut tête et au milieu ici et c'est
ouais mais ils vont ils vont tous venir
y vont oui mais ils vont croire qu'elles
font
ça sonne ça
mais au village
tous les jours à 10h du soir quelqu'un
tape comme ça pour dire aux dames 2
n'est pas oubliée la pilule ah bon pour
le contrôle de naissance fait ça bon oui
les bâtiments jaune là bas est utilisée
encore au l'appartement du sultan assez
là où ils habitent oui il habite
toujours ici avec sa famille
le pavillon central du palais représente
le volcan merapi autour de ce point
culminant les autres pavillons sont les
différentes îles de l'archipel dalles de
marbre lustres en verre de venise
vitraux hollandais c'est un mélange
incroyable et c'est incroyable
à java le centre du toit supporté par
les quatre piliers est la partie la plus
sacrée de la maison
c'est du tech là le bois qui est utilisé
c'est du tech les quatre piliers du
pavillon central du palais symbolise les
quatre éléments de l'univers tout entier
la terre l'eau elle a fait l'avant
ouais nord
sud
et
l'est au milieu c'est le masque du
gardien de la terre
c'est ce que nous croyons ici
le style javanais à son vrai code
couleur rouge pour le courage le noir
c'est la couleur de la terre mais pour
les vêtements il y a trois couleurs
aussi bleu blanc marron
bichonne ou brahma shiva
créateur protecteur destructeur
[Musique]
le palais du kratos est sous la menace
permanente des dieux en colère
en 2006 le volcan merapi s'est fâché il
a même cassé une partie du temple
hindouiste de prendre barran
ayoub jakarta un million et demi de
personnes vivent sous la menace du
volcan le dernier séisme 6,3 sur
l'échelle de richter a fait 6000 morts
plus de cent mille maisons détruits
[Musique]
pourtant les indonésiens s'affairent des
maisons solides il faut aller dans des
coins perdus de l'archipel pour
retrouver ce savoir faire ancestral
cap vers l'est direction sumba une des
îles les moins fréquentées de l'archipel
une île un peu à l'écart du monde
il n'y a pas si longtemps le peuple de
simba et est cannibale ici les
missionnaires catholiques ont dû passer
un deal avec la religion locale la
civilisation marasme
bien loin des influences coloniale je
viens voir comment on construit ces
maisons avec de drôles de toi
c'est impressionnant c'est megan est
allé aux
allées assouba les maisons une forme
unique au monde
la civilisation marabout a laissé
d'énormes mégalithes sur la place des
villages anciens lieux de prière où les
habitants pratiquer le culte des
ancêtres
parce qu'on est là
[Musique]
sa place du village là c'est ça
la matière
[Musique]
les maisons sous bat son plein de
symboles
ces deux pièces de bois ouvragé au
sommet de la toiture par exemple elle
raconte l'harmonie entre la femme et
l'homme c'est pas beau ça
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien voir à l'intérieur
par une porte j'aperçois le longa
symbole de longévité qui décorent les
piliers
l'ancien aperçu sur la place tout à
l'heure matière à l'ombre d'une toiture
base y mange ça c'est des noix de bétel
on les mélange avec du camphre
est ce qu'on peut voir votre maison à
l'intérieur non on peut pas rentrer dans
votre maison non non c'est interdit ah
bon edimbourg vous comprenez c'est tabou
là on est dans la partie commune c'est
la terrasse en bambou surélevée sur
pilotis à partie familiale la pièce
commune pour la famille rien de neuf à
la famille et les étrangers
pas facile de pénétrer dans une maison
awano kaka il fait 35 degrés à l'ombre
tout le monde est à l'abri des toitures
en herbe je suis le seul à me promener
en plein cagnard
finalement monsieur b courade et un
voisin accepte de nous recevoir il est
chrétien alors il m'autorise à rentrer
dans la partie interdite de la maison
[Musique]
les piliers centraux ça toute la
structure est en bois massif et tout le
reste tous les baffles ans le les
planches et les cloisons c'est du bambou
dans cette afrique là
quelqu'un d'une chambre qui est un peu
plus séparées pour avoir un petit peu
d'intimité mais sinon ils ceux qui
dorment à 10 ans reste
[Musique]
en dessous ses laitages des animaux ici
c'est les hommes et au dessus c'est le
mare à poule on parlait de l'ancien là
tout à l'heure
ils pensent que c'est à bon droit
revenir en 2006 commandes renault
juste un boulot
mais ça brille ça ça veut dire que c'est
plein je suis je te dis pas là
[Musique]
c'est le royaume des esprits dans la
civilisation marathon
s'est couvert de suivre
[Musique]
ah
oui si on voit les liens
tu pourras s'emballe
ça c'est la lia nothing leur état
[Musique]
ça doit protéger les suis là comme ça
qu'elle dépose protège la toiture des
insectes par l'intérieur
voilà il est déjà
à courir il n'y a pas de l'assemblage
c'est uniquement poser c'est une cabane
s'est posé ça se tient là pouf pour
laquelle vont se poser d'autres contrées
ensuite les bonbons c'est étonnant c'est
vraiment du mouvement les liens végétaux
vous y découvrirez
suis là en bonne état
d'autant que peut les changer c'est ça
qui est bien ces modules avancés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai retapé cette maison quand
nous avons tué un cochon
c'est celui-là
les autres c'est chaque fois qu'il ya un
décès
est celui-là
c'est quand j'ai épousé ma femme
[Musique]
monsieur b cour ad à retaper cette
maison il ya quinze ans il a changé
l'herbe de la toiture et puis il a aussi
remplacé une partie des piliers
il m'a fallu presque un mois pour couper
le bois dans la forêt
j'ai taillé les troncs
j'ai fait du petit bois pour la
charpente
et j'ai aussi récupérer des lianes les
bambous et l'herbe
vous avez fait comment pour apporter les
troncs avec un battoir avait transporté
ses troncs bateau on a utilisé des
treuils
mais pourquoi aller si loin dans une
autre il n'y a pas de bois ici non il
n'ya pas de bois rare dans le secteur
des bois comme celui ci par exemple du
bois de caila y en a pas ici
[Musique]
au menu poulets grillés puis bouillis au
lait de coco on mange dehors sur la
terrasse en bambou va bien dormir là
ici pas d'eau pas d'électricité
bientôt coucher les mioches
[Musique]
le corps chante à 4 heures 15 ce matin
moi j'ai un peu de mal sur ma ligne et
en bambou à côté j'entends les filles
qui font déjà la vaisselle au dessus des
cochons
qu'est ce que vous cherchez on cherche
une boucle d'oreille commença à une
boucle d'oreille
oui elle est tombée de la cuisine
pendant la vaisselle
elle est tombée de la sicile a oui elle
devrait être par la police est dur à
trouver
des records car c'est comme ça dans le
signe est là c'est parce qu'ayant
postale nom
[Musique]
arrive souvent que les objets tombent
dans le fumier oui on retrouve des
couteaux des cuillères
après deux faciles qu'ils sont en train
d'abandonner
les recherches
ça y est tu là et la retrouver
[Musique]
finalement on l'a retrouvé sept boucles
d'oreilles après toutes ces émotions on
est parti à la salle de bain
moi je rêvais déjà d'autres il l'abat
plus à l'ouest
[Musique]
si le peuple de sumba a fait ces maisons
adaptées au climat et aux ressources
locales pour découvrir un parfait
exemple de l'harmonie il faut aller à
bali
[Musique]
à 500 kilomètres des cochons de monsieur
b cours à des vers l'ouest l'île de bali
changement de décor
[Musique]
vous allez voir des endroits comme choix
aval il y en a pas mal c'est aussi ce
qui donne à cette île cette image de
paradis à l'art de l'habitat un art de
construire la maison qui ne tient pas au
hasard tout en finesse dans cette éviter
bali est la seule île hindouiste de
l'archipel indonésien
en hiver toutes les divinités même celle
de la nuit
[Musique]
sega neige qui m'accueille ganesh le
dieu hindouiste protecteur de la maison
je déboule dans la maison du grand
prêtre du good une sorte de labyrinthe
avec plusieurs passages entre différents
pavillons
et des petits hôtels ont fait des offres
parfois
pleins de divinités à bagnères
on vient consulter le prêtre pour lui
demander des conseils sur le succès la
prospérité de la famille et sur la tenue
de la maison
n'importe les offrandes nature même de
la voir leur prêtre toutes des pièces
annexes on prépare des offrandes
mcafee
et des temples dans toutes les maisons
hong kong et d'éviter fait partie de la
maison
[Musique]
avant même de commencer la construction
de la maison ils font tout série de
prières des mantras pour sélectionner
les bois dans la forêt
à bali les maisons dégage un sentiment
d'harmonie sûrement parce qu on les
construit en suivant un code bien
particulier les gens à bali déjà
plusieurs pavillons au lieu de la
végétation et les familles ont ils sont
disposés pas par hasard ils sont
disposés selon des textes sacrés tout
appel
stack au zanaco sa liste
après
charlie chaplin qui est venue la regarde
ben ali dans les années 30 était un des
premiers artistes
combiné occidentaux avoir flashé sur ban
na li pas c'est incroyable de le
retrouver sur l'eau ce que j'aime bien
c'est pierre ailes sont recouvertes de
mousse la moindre pierre avec l'humidité
je viens voir le prêtre pour qu'il
m'explique ces fameuses règles de la
stac aux à la cause ali elle détermine
l'emplacement des pavillons les uns par
rapport aux autres
la largeur des pièces bref toutes les
règles qui servent à bâtir une maison
impressionnant
salut
id apps et d'engager des à 72 ans sa
famille vit dans cette maison depuis
sept générations
à bali trois religions influencé la
culture de l'île un mélange qui vient de
très loin vie assez lent et l'indochine
par exemple les règles de mesure de la
maison balinaise viennent de grèce
vous voulez dire la grèce en europe oui
en grèce d'abord et après à bali
la grèce incroyable
plus incroyable encore les balinais
considèrent leur maison comme un corps
humain la tête c'est pour les dieux le
corps pour les hommes les intestins et
les jambes pour les démons
une bonne averse et un café plus tard id
apps et d'engager des accepte de me
montrer ces fameux texte qu'il a
soigneusement recopié à la main
les originaux sont gardés sur dead
le palmier
j'aime pas ça
en bas
tout ça ce sont les règles
ça commence là
ces règles anciennes qui ont toujours
cours aujourd'hui fixent même le système
de mesure pour construire les maisons
c'est le départ asta mousty
oui c'est vrai pour mesurer la maison
balinaise on utilise le corps humain
on prend la longueur de l'index pour les
grands piliers
et pour les petits on prend cette
distance là et on calcule comme ça la
longueur et la largeur de toute la
maison
mousty c'est la distance des deux bras
ouverts à l'horizontale
dépassé la mesure entre le coude et
l'extrémité de la main et à se tasser la
longueur du pouce ce sont les mesures
pour construire les temples
épatant ses textes sacrés
j'apprends encore qu'à ben ali les toits
des maisons ne doivent pas dépasser la
hauteur des cocotiers une règle simple
dont le résultat est immédiat les
maisons sont fondus dans le paysage
les règles de la stac aux à la cause ali
linda garlande les connaît sur 10
hectares de terrain dans un des coins
les plus préservés de ben ali elle a
construit son petit coin de paradis cinq
maisons en bois exotique le long de la
rivière
c'est l'endroit magique
[Musique]
regarde cette maison on regarde de tous
les enfants
[Musique]
j'aime bien comme la végétation a envahi
toute la maison dans les joints des
pierres et pouget ont poussé sur le bord
du toit de chaume les animaux partout
fourmi qui courent les oiseaux dans et
devant nous
ça l'habitat tropical
la nature est dans la maison
linda garland dette irlandaise styliste
docteur en philosophie linda est classé
dans le top 50 des designers mondiaux
elle a décoré la maison de david bowie
aux caraïbes et fait découvrir ben ali à
mick jagger qui vient se reposer ici
ravi de vous rencontrer moi aussi
je suis
c'est un endroit incroyable merci la
nature et les styles de l'année oui la
nature est avant toute chose c'est aussi
la fin à j'aime votre endroit merci
vous êtes allé dans cette maison à côté
larchitecture tribales et pratique la
manière dont les maisons attrape le vent
la bonne tombe des toits pour la pluie
les bons choix pour les tremblements de
terre tout cela est très fonctionnel
c'est une histoire de bon sens ils ne
font pas de maison stupide doit vivre
dedans et on fait pareil si
l' architecture ici ce sont les éléments
naturels
il ne s'agit pas de savoir quel look ça
va avoir mais plutôt comment tout ça
fonctionne avec la nature
à ravir
mais c'est qu'un début main
larchitecture des maisons de linda est
inspiré par le style tribal de ben ali
et aussi d'autres îles de l'archipel
j'aime bien stoddart c'est top
c'est calme et si la nuit
tout le monde est bien cet endroit on y
dort bien oui on peut se relaxer et
passer une bonne nuit
la piste
[Musique]
c'est vrai il y a une nature magnifique
mais surtout les gens leur culture et
leur équilibre sont encore en harmonie
vous savez les villages les communautés
fonctionne comme une seule personne
si quelqu'un est faible les autres
membres de la communauté prenne en
charge sa faiblesse on pourrait
rapprocher cela de l'idée de la
compassion dans le bouddhisme en tout
cas les gens sont raides et tout n'est
pas dictée par la réussite individuelle
baisse de jardin c'est ça oui de java
ces titres n'est ce pas ça c'est un
style de travail très particulier du
bois qui vient de java
on s'imagine pas là pour les panneaux la
chambre
asseyez vraiment les belles pièces belle
fille zohra
un peu cher ces gens 350 $ la nuit mais
bon c'est quand même
là ça j'adore toi
tu te la tétée tranquille regarde le
regarde comme ça tu as les fougères
bon
de l'architecturé indonésienne
traditionnel à des espaces très publique
et d'autres vraiment très privé
ici les parties privées sont les
chambres où on est assuré d'avoir de
l'intimité garantit aux clients la
tranquillité mais finalement c'est ça le
luxe non
et puis on a un endroit où les
hélicoptères peuvent se poser là bas
dans la forêt comme ça les clients
arrivent en toute discrétion vous savez
et certains clients ont besoin de sens à
votre santé à la vôtre merci
les clients et s'ils sont au coeur de la
nature et ils se sont vraiment à l'aise
quand vous avez réglé tous vos soucis
matériels pour réfléchir à vos problèmes
existentiels il vous reste le clou du
spectacle de bridge un pont au dessus de
la rivière
alors là ça dépasse tous là
au dessus de la rivière
avec son petit air frais qui descend à
j'aime vraiment cet endroit
c'est étonnant
shi
bon là je pense que ça
peut arriver quelque part quoi
c'est en duo la regarde ça y est you
bring up il ose
linda garlande a construit son petit
coin de paradis avec des matériaux de
récupération
pas seulement pour faire bobo mais parce
qu'à ben ali on ne trouve presque plus
de bois d'oeuvre et plus à l'ouest à
sumatra c'est pire
pas facile de partir de ben ali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ouais
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
monop et mon devoir
[Musique]
sumatra je me suis réveillé un beau
matin et j'ai vu ça
[Musique]
j'étais arrivé au pays minangkabau
minangkabau ça veut dire buffle
victorieux
[Musique]
c'est un tueur la laisser ça s il
décolle toutes là on n'est pas bien
je viens voir des maisons avec des
drôles de toi est d'abord ce palais
royal
[Musique]
côté
saint paul de mélange
le peuple me langue était passé maître
dans l'art d'utiliser les essences
locales de bois pour construire ces
maisons là bas tout ça car c'est la
porte d'entrée vers une région qui a
fait le tannat data qui est considéré
comme le berceau historique de sumatra
toutes les grandes dynasties princière
les sultans avait le royaume ici ce qui
est drôle c'est que c'est tout travail
ou les fenêtres sont pas des caire
les piliers sont penchés comme ça
traverse
un seul grand espace central et avec ses
piliers l'écartement entre chaque pilier
ça devait faire le saut d'un cheval
ici toutes les maisons sont construites
sur le modèle de ce palais comme lost
mais aujourd'hui au pays minangkabau peu
de maisons sont encore en état la tôle
ondulée a remplacé les corses de sabou
ancestrales
pas facile de trouver du bois d'oeuvre
il part surtout à l'exportation
et ça marche
rigaux hello
sur quoi
ça fait une grande surface à
ça c'est un des 26 à la maison vous
allez vraiment attaquer
je regardais la maison elle est
tellement belle
youzhny marais la patronne de la maison
construite dans les années 30 par son
arrière-grand-père
plusieurs générations vivent ensemble
ici mais la maison est un sale état
c'est la grand parti comme une grande
salle commune les invités sont là et les
parties privées qui sont une succession
de pièces comme ça
oh [ __ ]
tu participes passés par les sectes à
rien ça c'est quand même embêtant
j'aurais pété leur leur plancher comme
s'en fiche
il
à côté de l'espace commun qu'on appelle
le pont canal il y a les chambres les
pièces là votre chambre à l'est où là
bas au nord
vous pouvez vous montrez votre chambre
d'accord
mais moi je veux voir les
oui
ça c'est là
ça c'est la première chose
ou est ce qu'elle est partie alors
[Musique]
dans les maisons minhang en vieillissant
on change de chambre toujours en
tournant dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre qui est et après quand une
nouvelle fille de la maison est en âge
de se marier la maîtresse de maison il
laisse sa chambre petit à petit on
pousse les anciens de pièce en pièce et
finalement ils se retrouvent pas loin de
la fenêtre
[Musique]
vous savez avant c'était dur de trouver
un mari
par exemple quand un invité arrivaient
les parents nous demander d'aller nous
cacher dans les chambres là derrière et
nous ont regardés par derrière les
portes
qu'à la rigole on peut monter voir en
haut
oui bien sûr elle est rude
justin jeter un oeil sur la toiture
on y voir un peu cette voiture de
l'intérieur
ouais
[Musique]
il ya quatre rangées de cinq filles et
ses maisons de taille moyenne
[Musique]
un
tremblement de terre l'an dernier a
démoli la cuisine depuis youzhny marc
bricole avec les moyens du bord
aujourd'hui ses voisines lui donne un
coup de main
[Musique]
c'est le séisme qui a cassé l'ancienne
on a fait celle là au même niveau que la
maison
je n'avais pas assez d'argent pour la
reconstruire oui c'est vrai c'est cher
les plaques de tôle son cher et en plus
c'est difficile de trouver le bon bois
midi lors de la grande prière du
vendredi
[Applaudissements]
ici dans la maison de justes ni marc
comme le veut la coutume les femmes
mangent séparées des hommes
alors c'est bon ah oui c'est très bon
c'est moi oui vraiment
papa baba sms ça veut dire si en cas de
problème en soi sms qu'on pourrait faire
sens pour elle rend briatexte pour le
second
ustream armes invite à revenir la
prochaine fois j'espère que sa maison va
tenir le coup pendant les prochains
séismes
mais comment faire plus solide
pas très loin du pays bas tous en quarts
on a trouvé des solutions pour résister
aux tremblements de terre direction
l'ancien royaume de niasse
[Musique]
un bimoteur à hélices pour la dernière
étape du voyage
au large de sumatra je file sur l'île de
niasse
un climat pas facile 200 jours de pluie
par an mais ici le danger vient de la
mer des célèbres dynamique
[Musique]
la première parade contre les tsunamis
c'est bien sûr de s'installer en hauteur
les villages traditionnels se trouvent à
l'intérieur des terres
c'est incroyable cette rue centrale
les villages à niasse ils sont comme ça
avant il était bordée de palissades pour
se protéger
c'est une rue une des centrales et donc
se trouvaient face à face
c'est bien social
construit sur une colline tout le
village est pavée et un système de
rigoles draine les eaux de pluie
vous êtes en train de reconstruire votre
maison à cause du séisme ça
vous savez il ya eu un racisme il ya
très peu de temps
amat la terre tremble tous les jours ici
mais les maisons résiste
la partie arrière était abîmée mais elle
n'est pas complètement détruite juste
les bois se sont déplacés
les maisons ont résisté aux derniers
séismes grâce à leur construction bien
spéciale un système de pilotis croisés
c'est des constructions antisismiques
mais voir la maison du roy c'est la plus
grande c'est laisser les maisons les
plus grosses maisons en bois massif
des maisons monumental
celle du roi de niasse est la plus
grande de lille 24 mètres de haut
soixante six piliers porte l'édifice
incroyable ici les maisons sont en ébène
et 7 mai belge c'était exceptionnel
[Musique]
gigantesque
on sait anti68 en plus ces constructions
parce que les pieds sont très gros
grandmaster du massif et en plus la
construction est fait de telle manière
que la partie de l'habitation ça toutes
sortes de boîtes même si la maison est
secouée comme ça
chaque hôtel deuxième tombé sur le côté
mais ça ne casse pas
si ça cartonne à en 2006 et a eu
8 8 sur l'échelle de richter puisqu'on
est à l'endroit où la plaque de l'océan
indien s'enfonce sous la plaque
asiatique
mille morts sur l'île de nias s'il y a
deux ans mais en bas sur la côte dans
les maisons modernes en béton ici
presque toutes les maisons ont résisté
ah enfin une maison sans meubles ça
c'est bon ça
le roi de niasse avait son petit loft de
150 m² avec cet immense cheminée
tout est en bois exotique ras du sol au
plafond
magnifique du solide
il vend 40 80 120 140 la taille de
trouver c'est des belles pièces
[Musique]
csii a dit m
charest
j'hallucine sur la quantité de poudre
dans la charpente là aussi sur
dimensionnées pour résister aux
secousses elles sont extraordinaires
sens je me suis pas ça comme ça
assez puissant les maisons de niasse
sont aussi plein d'astuces ça fait
différents étages comme ça on peut
surveiller
que année à ce qu'on trouve ça dans
l'indonésie
seller sorte de banque est là où on peut
surveiller ce qui se passe dans le
village on off est
obligé de se protéger des colères de la
terre lenya soit en ont fait leur maison
de solides
après il restait à se protéger de la
pluie 250 jours par an quand même il
fallait trouver une solution
[Applaudissements]
incroyable
[Musique]
bon j'espère que cette exploration des
maisons tropicales d'indonésie vous a
plu on pourrait faire facilement un
deuxième épisode dans ce pays tellement
il ya des cultures différentes et donc d
architecture particulière
bon je vous laisse je vais aller surfer
là goundry cette vague célèbre qui a été
découverte par des surfeurs australiens
dans les années 60 je rigole je vais me
faire un bon poisson en terrasse ciao
[Musique]
par deux
il
[Musique]
eau salée
les caisses de poisson